um
all right
um
all right well hello and welcome to the
science institute
my name is peter bartlett i'm the
associate director here we run these
collaborative programs every semester
and uh
welcome to the first workshop
for the program on
the computational complexity of
statistical entrance
um
we've got a uh we need to say thank you
to the nsf for its support of this
program through uh
the foundations of data science
institute
and this this first workshop is called
rigorous evidence for information
computation trade-offs
a big thank you to the organizers to sam
hopkins
lenkes deborova and alfonzo bandera
let's thank them
it's a exciting program i'll hand over
to sam in a moment to introduce the
workshop
i want to say a few words about
logistics you
should have discovered the food and and
drinks
outside
there for the breaks for lunch you're on
your own
there are
lockers across the across the way on the
far side of the building on this level
if you need to leave some things here
um
we have everything going in a hybrid
format this morning so um you know there
are zoom speakers and uh
uh
audience on zoom uh as well as the usual
video on youtube and and the website so
everything's being archived
our videographer in the booth here is
omid farr we'll be helping out with
hooking up computers
and so on
also just to introduce kelani pendleton
in the back
so she's the one that's done she and
ashley hassan i've done all the local
arrangements for
the workshop this week
uh so a big big thank you to kalani and
ashley also
and if you have logistical questions uh
kalani is the one to ask
uh throughout the week okay sam
thanks peter
so it's amazing to see all of you here
uh for this kind of amazing reunion
we realize the world is still tumultuous
place and some of you are on zoom so
welcome to our zoom audience hello i
think that's the camera
um
we're doing something a bit new we're
trying we have a mirror workshop going
on this week at epfl on tuesday
wednesday and thursday so a bunch of our
european participants are converging
there they will have their own talks in
european morning and then tuesday
wednesday and thursday we will have some
joint sessions uh that i hope you'll
join us for with talks and questions
from both from both audiences
so we've opted for a pretty broad
interpretation of the subject matter so
you'll see that we'll we're going to
deepen our investigation of some themes
which came up already in the boot camp
statistical query algorithms low degree
algorithms some squares algorithms
approximate message passing overlap gap
property things like this
but we also have a bunch of talks from
kind of adjacent areas and we're hoping
that we can take this opportunity to
build new connections so we have talks
about landscape of high dimensional
optimization proof complexity worst case
to average case reductions average case
to average case reductions time space
trade-offs we even have some talks about
quantum computing and quantum
information and
on differential privacy
so we're hopeful that we've brought
together sort of a crowd with enough
overlapping interests to make some
progress but a disparate enough set of
expertise that we can build new
connections uh we hope we will take this
opportunity of being here in person to
actually have some of those
conversations
uh logistically
to the folks on zoom to lower the burden
on the session chairs we're probably not
monitoring the chat super carefully so
please unmute yourself and ask questions
feel free if you are a zoom uh panelist
and you can see questions from zoom
participants who can't unmute themselves
if you could just raise those questions
for us that'd be great
um
you'll notice because of the overlapping
session with epfl we do have a slightly
different schedule tuesday wednesday and
thursday as compared to today and friday
in particular we have a pretty early
start i'm hopeful to see some of you
here for uh for talks that overlap with
epfl uh the next few days um and as a
reward we get out early on tuesday
wednesday and thursday i think talks are
over at 2 15 or something and there's
plenty of time to talk and on friday
afternoon michael celentano has been
voluntold to uh lead a hike in the
berkeley hills for all of us so thank
you michael you can meet him um
outside the building at two on friday
we'll remind you of that a couple times
uh finally thank you to alfonzo and
lenka my co-organizers you were awesome
thank you to guy and salil who gave us
the opportunity to organize this uh
thanks to the simon stuff you are all
awesome this couldn't happen without you
uh so let's move on to the first session
it's my pleasure to introduce pravesh
kothari um and after him aaron patechan
due to some um organizer cronyism the
workshop is kicking off with two of my
oldest collaborators talking about uh
subject near and dear to my heart
pravesh and aaron have been at the
center of developments on uh sum of
squares algorithms and lower bounds for
the last
five or more years um
take it over profession
all right can you hear me
thanks for the
fantastic introduction sam
uh thanks also for organizing this
workshop to sam lenka and afonso giving
me the chance to talk in person after
like more than a year and all of us
hanging out in berkeley that's super
great so i want to tell you about a very
recent work
on refuting constrained satisfaction
problems
uh jointly with an amazing graduate
student at cmu peter manohar and my
colleague mike guriswami
so let me start by telling you the
central object of interest in this talk
which is this
algorithm called a refutation algorithm
okay
so a reputation algorithm gets as input
an instance fee of a constraint
satisfaction problem
and for the duration of the talk my
running example of a csp would be the
ksat problem
so this is simply the csp where you know
you have start process each of width k
okay
so given such an instance p of k sat
with m clauses and n variables the goal
of a refutation algorithm is to output a
value v in 0 1 says that v is an upper
bound
on value of v
by value of v i simply mean the maximum
fraction of constraints that the best
possible truth assignment of the
variables can satisfy
okay
now we say that the algorithm succeeds
in weakly refuting the instance fee
if it outputs a value which is strictly
less than one and the way you should
think about it is that in this case the
algorithm is giving you a convincing
certificate
that the input instance is unsatisfied
you can you know be more demanding and
ask for a strong refutation in which
case the value should be less than one
minus delta for some absolute constant
delta bigger than zero and in this case
the algorithm is convincing you with a
certificate that no more than one minus
delta fraction of the constraints can be
satisfied by any assignment
okay
now
this is the natural co np analog of the
problem of solving max k constraint
satisfaction problems that you might be
more familiar with and in the worst case
these problems are actually equally hard
so our goal
would be to find the largest possible
family of instances t they have got to
be unsatisfiable if i've got to refute
them
for which you know i can get
non-trivially efficient algorithms
okay so that's my goal
a lot is known for this problem and i'm
going to summarize our state of
knowledge
in two slides okay
i'm going to start with first the worst
case story here okay so here's what we
know for worst case case at instances
the problem so you know this curve by
the way you know has
um the number of constraints drawn in
log scale on the x-axis
and the best running time we know for
refuting worst case instances with a
given number of constraints on the
y-axis okay
so in general you know you should expect
that csps should get easier or refuting
csp should get easier if you have more
constraints you know intuitively is
because you know if you have more
constraints you can hope for like some
local violations to arise and you could
you know use those local violations to
conclude that no assignment can satisfy
all constraints okay
regardless of this intuition it turns
out that in the worst case
algorithms you know notice like you know
there's a non-trivially sub-exponential
time algorithm meaning better than like
you know let's say brute force two to
the omega and time algorithms
only when m exceeds n to the k minus 1
okay that's the first inflection point
then there's the sub exponential time
algorithm which becomes a polynomial
time if you have omega n to the k
constraints
so what i want you to remember from this
is the two relevant points where the
curve changed
at n to the k minus one and above there
is a sub exponential time algorithm and
at n to the k and above there is a
polynomial time algorithm
okay
let me draw the same picture for random
instances of k sat nam okay by random
instance i mean that variables in each
clause are chosen uniformly randomly and
independently and then the literal
patterns on the variables are again
chosen uniformly randomly and
independently okay so both the so-called
clause structure or instance hypergraph
is random and the literal patterns are
random
this is natural to study if you were
like you know depressed by the grim
picture in the previous slide and indeed
you know you get significant gains in
the sense that the picture looks
significantly different from the one we
just drew for worst case k sat problem
okay so what do we know about this well
it turns out that there is a special
number n to the k over 2
that is often called the spectral
threshold
beyond which there are polynomial time
algorithms for refuting k-stat instances
okay it's called the spectral threshold
because as i'll
soon show you
uh the algorithm that does this is a
certain spectral algorithm okay
but actually even below n to the k over
2 you can get a non-trivial improvement
over root 4 search there is like a
non-trivial structure in the problem
even below this density
in particular you know that for any
integer parameter l
there is an n to the o of l time
algorithm that succeeds in refuting so
long as you have this weird
many constraints okay and actually it's
not so weird and the way i like to read
this trade-off is really in the way it's
written here so here's a way to
understand it
let's see if i remember how to use a
clicker
oh hey
all right you know so this term stays
the same
and when l grows from one through n
the second term goes from n to the k y
to minus one to basically order one so
what's happening is as l increases
the lower bound on m required
goes from n to the k over two to n so in
some sense the
parameter l
gives you a way to interpolate linearly
in the exponent of n the number of
constraints and so what's happening is
that you know
um there is a linear relationship
between the exponent of n in m and the
running time we know for refuting
instances with that many constraints
okay
and you know
as just an example if you were to
specialize in the case of presat
then it turns out there's a two to the
end to the delta time algorithm for any
tiny delta that succeeds whenever you
have n to the 1.5 minus delta over 2
constraints okay
good so
that's not all there is an even more
interesting behavior that seems to
happen in the case of random case at
instances
there's a third interesting point of the
curve discovered in this work of phi gay
came and opec a really fascinating work
and some extensions proved in david
whitmer's cmu thesis
basically this results show that there
are polynomial time verifiable
refutations meaning polynomial time
verifiable certificates
that can convince you of
unsatisfiability of you know random
instances with
number of constraints which is
polynomially below the spectral
threshold okay so there is some constant
delta k says that if you have only n to
the k over 2 minus delta k constraints
for that many constraint instance you
still have with high probability a
certificate that will convince you of
unsatisfiability
the key difference of course is that we
don't know any polynomial time algorithm
to find such certificates in fact the
best algorithm we know runs in some
fixed sub exponential time regardless
they exist
okay and we don't know of an analog of
this phenomenon in the worst case so
this is like some truly new phenomenon
that we are seeing in the random case
okay
good so you know we saw two pictures
that's the summary of the knowledge of
you know solving k sat or refuting k sat
and if you're a complexity theorist at
this point you know
you might be wondering well you know how
does the complexity of ksat interpolate
between these two extreme worlds right
one might get the sense that random ksat
is perhaps too idealistic it's a
specific natural distribution after all
you know maybe like my instances are not
going to look as random case that
instances do or you might think that the
worst case picture is too pessimistic
there are non-trivial algorithmic
techniques that people invented for
solving the random instances you might
think well do they apply to more general
random instances or not and in general
you might be wondering
how much randomness is needed for these
techniques to actually work for our
refutation algorithm to succeed right
does claw structure need to be random
the literal patterns do they need to be
random and so on okay
so what i want to tell you today the
main punch line of this talk is that
modulo whether you buy the next model
makes sense or not
there is a satisfactory resolution to
all these questions
okay so let me tell you this model and
let me tell the main results
the model is the smooth csp model
introduced by phi gay in 2007 and here
is what it does it starts from a worst
case instance so like absolutely
arbitrary instance
and then you just perturb the literal
patterns independently with some small
constant probability let's say 0.01 okay
so the thing to notice is that the claw
structure or the so-called instance
hypergraph is completely arbitrary
only the literal patterns have this you
know small amount of randomness
introduced by the random perturbation
now you know it's very easy to prove
that with high probability over the
choice of the smoothness
the true value of the resulting smoother
instance drops you know in fact is
bounded away from one with high
probability okay and so it's legit to
ask the question of refuting such
instances and that's exactly what i get
it
and the main result of this talk the
algorithmic result of this talk
is actually this picture now this
picture might look exactly the same
as the one we drew for random and that's
by design because that's exactly the
result that we can draw the exact same
curve
for refuting random
exact same curve for defining smoother
instances strongly repeating smoother
instances as we could for random
instances okay
so that's the main algorithmic result uh
let me just like quickly tell you about
the context of this result what we knew
earlier so i already told you what they
knew for random
for more general instances much less is
known so you know this work of figer
gave a weak refutation algorithm instead
of a strong one that we are getting now
for the case of smooth three sat
instances
with end to the 1.5 clauses okay so this
algorithm was a polynomial term
algorithm that worked for that many
constraints
now you know to actually get this
algorithm figure invented a
combinatorial notion of refutation
certificates that's what he used to get
this
and as a result they generalized to
three csps other three csps but not to
you know id4 csps or not to strong
reputation okay
and finally you know there is this
recent work in fact the direct
inspiration and precursor to this work
which
uh you know occurred in a joint work
with venkat and my student jacksonvasco
last year
where we give a strong refutation
algorithm
for a slightly weaker model than smooth
is called the semi-random model uh
briefly speaking it just means that you
know instead of perturbing the literals
you are completely going to set them to
random values okay that's what
semi-random means so for semi-random
k-stat instances we give a polynomial
time algorithm with n to the k over two
constraints so you can think of this as
getting
you know one end of the curve so let me
like summarize the knowledge to you so
that you don't bother by the
bounce yes uh some question about this
smooth case model so yes if you're
perturbing every every every literal
with probability 0.01 then there's still
for every clause there's a constant
probability that every that every
literally
randomized yes so don't you just have a
semi-random instance hiding in your
solutions yes absolutely okay so these
so so should i really think of
semi-random as a weaker model yeah yeah
i mean um um
it wasn't a two to the k or something so
so so here's the cool thing right like
for the purpose of strong reputation the
two models are exactly the same
by exactly the argument you just said
but for weak reputation you need to
worry about these things
you know because for weak refutation you
are proving really is less than one
bound and you know that can actually
like okay in some sense
the techniques we have for weak
refutation don't really go between
smooth and semi-random case easily but
for strong in fact that's exactly going
to be the case in fact most of the talk
the technical part of it i'm only going
to focus on semi-random which you
anticipated
perfect so to summarize our status of
knowledge
for random we knew this trade-off for
semi-random meaning one end of the
trade-off meaning l equals of one case
and for smoothie we knew of no strong
reputation algorithm even for threesat
good so that's the algorithmic result
what about this fko style certificates
so again exactly the same curve now we
can draw even for smoother ksat
instances okay in other words we're
going to we're going to be able to prove
that there is some density n to the k
over 2 minus delta k for some fixed
constant delta k at which polynomial
size certificates of unsatisfiability
exist for all smooth case at instances
yes
or for other cst yeah excellent question
so case that is my running example but
you know there is a right generalization
of all the results both algorithms and
certificates to all csps okay
and so yeah you can ask me offline about
them but i want to focus on ksr just for
the sake of whatever numbers being easy
and
exposition being somewhat simple
good so that's the result
so you can think of this as a
generalization of in fact you know i
would argue in a simplification of the
fko result to uh arbitrary clause
structures like no randomness
and the key ingredient which i want to
spend a few minutes on is a resolution
of a conjecture that figure made in
okay
now if you were you know
bothered by all these curves and bounds
etc i ask that you know you can come
back up because i'm going to tell you a
completely plain pure combinatorial fact
which has ostensibly nothing to do with
csp reputation which makes sense without
any csps
and so you know you can enjoy it without
even following whatever i said so far
okay
so
fighters conjecture is a certain
extremal conjecture about girth of
hypergraphs okay
in order to understand it
let's try to ask it for graphs now
what's the phi gas conjecture if it were
to be made for you know just plain
simple graphs that we have point of okay
so here's the question
suppose you have a graph on n vertices
and n times d over two edges for some
parameter d
okay the reason i'm writing it in some
awkward way like this is because you
know i want to think of d as the average
degree of the graph okay
so my question is what is
the
maximum possible girth of such a graph
as in what is the maximum possible
length of the smallest cycle that can
happen in such a graph
okay if d is 2 then the number of edges
in the graph is exactly n there's got to
be one cycle
and you can really take the graph which
has you know is a single n cycle
so clearly in this case you can make a
graph with that many edges and a cycle
of length n
and no smaller which means that in this
case you know the girth can be as large
as n
it turns out that if d is even tiny bit
bigger than two then the girth drops to
logarithmic factors in it
so in particular alone hurry and lineal
prove
the maximum cuts of such a graph is up
to a factor two simply log to the base d
minus one of n
okay and turns out that up to this
factor two this bound is in fact even
sharp you know we have some explicit
grammar rhythm families
so that's the question for graphs and we
want to ask the same question for three
and more generally k uniform graphs or
high k uniform hyper graphs
okay
well before that you know i have to tell
you what does it mean to be a cycle in a
hyper graph so we're going to like you
know identify some property of a cycle
in a graph and then use it to generalize
a cycle
you can think of in a graph as a sub
graph meaning a collection of edges
that touches every vertex and even
number of times
right
in fact if you're going to define a
cycle in a graph exactly in this way you
would come up with the same girth part
so that's what we're going to use to
extend to hypergraphs okay
so
some people call them even covers
as you'll see very soon why
because a hypergraph cycle generalizing
this definition is simply a collection
of hyperedges
that touch each vertex of the hypergraph
an even number of times
okay
so you know um uh if there are like some
people who enjoy coding here in the
audience
or like maybe feel better about coding
theoretical interpretations then one
reason you know people care about people
in coding theory care about you know
hypercraft cycles and fighters
conjecture is because it lead you know
it actually relates to rate distance
tradeoffs for linear codes of certain
kinds okay
so um why so how does this connection
come about
so you can think of a key uniform
hypograph as describing a set of
coefficients to linear equations modulo
2.
simply think of each hyperedge as
telling you which coefficients are set
to 1 in the corresponding equation
if you do that then a cycle is simply a
subset of equations which are linearly
dependent
you know in the binary field in f2
and so a hybrid graph cycle is simply
the length of the smallest linear
dependency
in a set of case parts linear equations
modular two okay
good
so now i can tell you what phi ga
conjectured so he conjectured that if
you have a k uniform hypergraph
with
n times n over l to the k over 2 minus 1
hyper edges
if this reminds you of the tradeoff we
wrote earlier for random ksat etc well
it's not an accident they are very
related
as a cycle of length about l again
okay
just to like make sense of it if you try
to specialize it to k equals 3 then this
is saying that if you have n to the 1.5
over square root of l
hyperedges in a three uniform hypergraph
then it must have a cycle of length l
log n
before even going further notice that
this is significantly different or
perhaps a little bit different at least
from the case of graphs in the case of
graphs if you have once you have like
more than n edges
it seems like it has like a log length
cycle
in this case however for you to see a
log n length cycle you need to have n to
the 1.5 hyperedges and then there is
like this trade-off
between the length of the cycle as the
number of hyper edges drop from n to the
1.5 to n
okay
all right
now you know because this is a weird
trade-off you might think well you know
this is the best possible thing when
good conjecture it turns out it is
because you can construct simply random
hypergraphs with slightly smaller than
this number of edges and prove that
there is no cycle of this length
so you know
if you want a cycle of this length
then even random hypographs tell you
that you're going to need at least that
many edges okay yes
so is this easy to see for regular uh or
like for the simple graph case if it's
regular it's quite easy to see yes i
actually don't know of a simpler proof
for a regular case either
it's a good question
so okay just maybe i'm getting ahead of
this but this number is the same as the
yes
absolutely so can you view like in the
reputation the spectral reputation
algorithm for the random case you do
this like trace moments calculation if
you want to bounce
some spectrum yeah and can you
reinterpret that calculation as like the
expected number of these uh exactly
versions like the ram
absolutely in fact yeah yeah this is the
only part that i'll actually do in the
clock so yeah sam you're anticipating
perhaps my slide number n minus one
uh yeah
absolutely
good so yeah that's the that's the
conjecture so let me you know tell you a
little bit about what we know about this
conjecture okay
so
first thing i'll tell you is that you
know even though this conjecture
ostensibly is only about a single l
organism cycle
you can you know very easily derive from
it that there are not just one
cycle of that length but in fact you can
have edge disjoint cycles about m over l
many of the same length and the proof is
very simple you know you take a cycle
and just like peel off all the
hyperedges and repeat on the residual
hypergraph
okay so that's great because this is the
connection that matters when you're
applying it to csp refutation
so you know what we know about this
conjecture is
for the random k uniform hypographs
this work of phi gay came and often this
was their key result this was their like
main combinatorial construction they
proved that for random k uniform
hypographs the conjecture is true
okay and because the graphs are random
they proved it you know the way we
actually proves the theorems in general
they use the second moment method you
know and like you're trying to
understand the probability that a
certain structure exists in a certain
random hypergraph so you're going to use
secondary method and argue that it
exists okay
for worst case hyper graphs
oh um actually let me skip this
connection right now for worst case
hyper graphs
the
the story so far is that you know we
know how to prove this conjecture for l
equal to one it was actually done in
this paper of asap now and were straight
and then you know improved uh you know
parameters a little bit by phi game
the upshot of all this works is that you
know for l equals of one we know that
the conjunction is true up to a factor
of log log n
uh the best bound for like larger l
however is due to alone and figure who
proved that you know for three uniform
hyper graphs
if you have n square while l many
hyperedges then in fact there is a log n
length cycle so this you know is off by
the true theta by a square root of n
over l factor okay
so long story short the summary of
previous works is that you know we kind
of know the conjecture for l equals one
and you know there were several
combinatorial approaches to attack this
conjecture but basically effectively
speaking would not know what happens
when l is larger than one
okay so now i can tell you what we do we
basically settle the connection we prove
that for every k and l i guess
conjecture is true up to a poly login
factor
the yes psychic bomb has an n square
versus n to the 1.5
so the
this so this result is in our birth
strain and phi gets one
it proves the conjecture for l equals o
of one
for this case we know the conjecture is
true up to like an additional factor of
log log n in the density m required so
in other words
we know that if you have n to the k over
2 times log log n many hyper edges in a
k uniform hyper graph then you know uh
there is a cycle of length or a log n
but we don't know you know this
conjecture for l bigger than one or we
didn't know
it for that case the alone 5k bound
actually holds for all l but it's a
weaker bound and it holds only for three
uniform hypergraphs if you know the
slack is root n over l here
good
perfect
so yeah so that's you know that's the
key result that actually goes into
proving this existence of certificates
that i was talking about earlier the
proof of fire gas conjecture and you
know as sam kind of anticipated the
argument is going to be you know a
spectral algorithm a spectral argument
instead of like a combinatorial one and
you know for um
i have to give it a name so i chose to
give it special double counting and i'll
try to justify it to you when i actually
show what this argument is but basically
you know it's a connection
between existence of hypergraph cycles
and sub exponential size reputations of
the kind that we were looking for you
know in our algorithm design question
okay so we're going to like settle this
purely combinatorial looking conjecture
by looking at you know our refutation
algorithms later on
that's it yes
for your actual result for like smooth
csps do you actually need the worst case
hypergraph result yes because they have
burst they hypergraphs
the smooth csp is the only smoothing is
in the literal patterns the hybrid types
are worse
right any more questions actually this
is a good time to stop the questions
because i'm done with the results
yes uh so
uh i guess uh as far as existence of
certificates are those existence of
certificate only for deep reputation or
also perfect excellent question so the
certificate i'm talking about are only
for the computation
actually don't know any certificate
for strong reputation below the spectrum
question
okay very good
so you know now i'm going to tell you
you know some acts on that
tell you how this results are actually
proven
and
well much of most of you know this
diagram if that is scary to you i won't
like touch most of the diagram in
the rest of the few minutes i have
but you know i'm going to explain to you
what the rough plan of this argument
looks like so by this connection that
sam was making earlier at the beginning
of the talk you can actually you know
think of you know you can essentially
just reduce strong reputation of
smoothie ksat to getting strong
reputation algorithms for semi-random
instances of the kx or csp so that's
like you know over here
so remember semi-random means that the
literal patterns are uniformly random
and kx or csp if you don't know what
that is you know it's basically you know
csp where the constraints are on k
variables and the constraints say that
the xor of them should be plus one or
zero or plus one or minus one depending
on which version of bits you work with
okay
um so our life's goal then becomes you
know refuting semi-random kxr instances
which you know we do by breaking into
two cases even and odd and as anybody
who's worked on csp refutation will tell
you the case of even is significantly
easier than the case of odd that's also
what happens you know in this result so
for even iot xr it turns out that you
can get this strong refutation algorithm
the kind of trade-off you're after
by combining one idea from this previous
work we had
with the right matrix
you know write matrix for csp definition
i'm going to explain this in more detail
to you very soon but this right matrix
was invented in this very clever work of
alex wein ahmed alawi and chris moore
and this this this matrix is you know in
some sense if i had to say one thing if
you have to remember one thing
about this whole work it's like you know
you've got to use kikuchi matrices okay
this matrix that alex chris and emma
defined
so what we'll be able to do is like take
this kikuchi matrices
and actually get the result for even
or by combining with this row bucketing
idea
so you know actually you know the goal
of this uh
wam paper was precisely to like simplify
the algorithms for tensor pca and even
add any random kxr reputation
for all those somehow there are
difficulties and so you know they did
not quite succeed so for add orality
we'll also introduce a variant of the
kikuchi matrix
and you know we'll have to do more stuff
here we'll jump through a few more hoops
which i won't talk too much in detail
but you know
basically there is a right kikuchi
matrix you can define even for the
ordinity case and make things happen for
this semi-random kx reputation problem
okay
the only thing i'm going to tell you
about today
is
you know why you should love kikuchi
matrices
so i'm going to tell you why the
structure of kikuchi matrices basically
solves all of your life problems
so that's all i'm going to try to
convince you of the rest of the talk
okay
perfect so let me tell you oh yeah i had
a fake einstein code to go with it
good
so i'm going to tell you um how first of
all you can use this kikuchi matrices
that w am defined to get even additi
random kxr reputation okay so all of
this none of this is our work this is
basically you know the older works and
vamp
i hope you don't mind alex and chris if
i call your paper ram
um so let's start with the case of l
equals of one okay so this in this case
we are trying to get polynomial
uh time refutation algorithms when you
have n to the k over two constraints
okay and we're looking at random
instances right now
so you know here is how 4x4 constraints
look like we are going to work in the
plus minus one world so then each
constraint looks like a product of some
four of the variables is set to plus or
minus one
so in general an instance of four x or
csp is defined by a four uniform
hypergraph that gives you which four
tuples of variables appear in
constraints
and a collection of right hand sides
which are simply plus minus 1 values b
sub 6.
okay
once you have such an instance you can
define a homogeneous degree 4 polynomial
if this notation looks scary to you it's
actually much simpler than it might look
look at this term here for every
constraint c which is a four tuple i
have x c 1 x e 2 x 3 x c 3 x c 4 which
is just the 4 x 1 monomial
corresponding to c which i have
multiplied with b sub c so in particular
if x satisfies this particular
constraint then this term here
contributes a plus one
and if it doesn't it contributes to
minus one okay
and all three x does is average this
plus or minus ones for each constraint
you know over all the constraints in the
hypergraph
reasonable
so you know you could think of what does
this vx do actually you know for any x
it computes the advantage over half of
the assignment x so in particular if px
is 0 it means that x satisfies exactly
how constraints if vx is 1 it means that
you know x satisfies all the constraints
visible
good so now our goal in life is to give
a refutation algorithm which means we
want to give a certificate that vx is at
most epsilon for some arbitrarily tiny
constant epsilon
okay
so here's the key idea which actually
you know appeared in this breakthrough
work long time ago when people
discovered spectral refutations in this
work of gert and tribulovic
and the idea is very simple we're going
to write vx as a quadratic form of a
certain matrix and you know once you
have that then we're going to use the
eigenvalue the spectral law of the
matrix in order to construct a
reputation
so let me tell you what that matrix is
here's the matrix in all its glory
the matrix is indexed by pairs of
variables
okay
i j and k l
and the i j k l entry is going to be b
sub i j k l if i j k l is a photo ball
that appears in your hyper graph
otherwise zero
okay very very simple
once you have such a matrix it's
actually not so hard to see that i can
write down phi x as a quadratic form of
this matrix
in fact you know if you see every i j k
l appears six times here because you
know there are four just two ways to
choose the row pair
and so you know that's this factor six
here so up to a factor six basically phi
x really just computes you know the
quadratic form
uh this vector by the way is simply the
vector of degree two monomials in the
assignment variable x
any questions so far this makes sense
so once i have you know this quadratic
form i can upper bound it like we do two
quadratic forms all the time so you know
i can upper bounded by the l2 square
norm of this x circle two
times the spectral now the matrix a
okay
so all that remains to be done so
because you can compute spectral norms
or at least arbitrarily approximate
spectral non-symbolic time all i need to
do
to get a refutation is to basically
prove that you know
um this object is small when the hyper
graph and the b sub c's are chosen
randomly okay
and here you know
basically any technique you throw the
any reasonable technique you throw at
the matrix actually works with fair ease
you know you can use turn off bound you
can use trace method whatever you can
prove that this you know the spectral
norm is appropriately small and be done
okay that's great you're done
now let's see how to get the full
tradeoff we did the case of l equals of
one with a very simple matrix
now we want to do the case of l bigger
than one okay so this result was first
proven
using a cleverly constructed symmetrized
tensor product matrix i'm not going to
define this matrix for you in this work
of raghvendra rao and sram okay
here's how we can think about it
we want to build a larger matrix that
gives us like a little bit more leverage
in terms of you know uh refutation
so the larger matrix that arises in the
word can be seen as like writing down
the matrix for a higher degree
polynomial obtained by like powering up
the initial polynomial you care about
okay
so for any parameter l you're going to
get like a matrix of size n to the o of
l roughly speaking
but for our case
the analysis you know in this work is
fairly technical
um and you know it kind of crucially
relies on the randomness of age
and you know i don't know how to
actually look at it and understand how
to extend it to arbitrary clause
structures or hypergraphs
instead
and like okay a bunch of words in fact
have tried to simplify this proof over
the years
and we are going to use one of the
simplifications okay but the key idea
the starting point of our work is going
to be the simplification that vam did
in this even led case of random kxr
expectation okay
so let me tell you what this matrix is
again the goal is to simply write phi x
as a quadratic form but the key thing is
this time we are going to write px
itself as a quadratic form not a power
of p
px itself would be a quadratic form of a
huge matrix like a bigger matrix okay
here's the matrix
this time it's indexed by subsets of the
variables of size exactly l
okay
you can think of the previous matrix as
the case that l was 2.
so now i have like blown up l i'm
looking at larger l
the entry corresponding to s comma t
equals b sub c if the symmetric
difference
of the sets indexing rows and column
happens to be equal to a constraint c
okay so i'm defining this matrix a sub c
for any fixed c in my hyper graph i'm
saying you know i'm going to write b sub
c here if symmetric difference equals c
otherwise zero okay now note that c is
of size four
s and t are of size l l can be as large
as a root n right
so this is a sparse matrix
it has entries only when the symmetric
difference is very small like four
so we don't mind we're going to work
with it anyway okay
our final matrix is simply going to be
the sum of this matrices for every c in
edge
okay
now just like before you can ignore the
whole expression if you want to believe
me if not you can share the expression
and convince yourself but basically 3x
is a quadratic formulas matrix up to
some appropriate scaling just like
before
okay
good so we can use the same strategy we
can upper bound using the spectral norm
of this matrix a
and you know the key observation that
works in our favor here is that a sub
c's are independent random matrices
so this time a is a sum of independent
random matrices and we can apply
off-the-shelf matrix concentration
inequalities in order to get hole
that's it
this gives you the right trade-off done
sorry this gives it to you even even for
arbitrary claw structure you just need
it's not for arbitrary classical random
right okay yeah yeah i'll see if i can
get to arbitrary clause success at the
end but for random we are done
okay
any questions
okay good
so
now
i want to
tell you
how
this particular matrix we just
constructed
can be used to prove fire gas conjecture
okay
and the way i'm going to tell you is by
proving this simple proposition which of
course we have several proofs for
but i'm going to prove it for you know
prove it with this idea that actually
generalizes very easily okay
so i'm going gonna prove that if you
take a four uniform hypograph random
this time and by the way this random is
simply because the analysis i just told
you for the matrix a was for the case of
random okay
but you'll see you know very soon that
this is a completely modular piece
so
start with a random four uniform hyper
graph with n square over l hyper edges
and i want to convince you that there is
a l log n length hyper graph cycle in
this hyper graph okay
here's the proof idea and it might sound
absurd but i'm going to read it out
anyway okay
it'll prove that if there is no even
cover if there is no l log n length
cycle
then
if i repeat the same refutation
algorithm i described in the previous
slide which by the way for like was for
random b sub c's
but this time i'll prove to you that if
there's there is no even cover of l log
and length
then regardless of the bc's that
algorithm will succeed in refuting
that's of course absurd because
i can choose b sub c's
in a way that the whole instance is
satisfiable so there is no way that i
can succeed in refuting for arbitrary b
substance
therefore
my assumption must be wrong therefore
there must be an l log and length even
covered in the hypergraph
okay
so if you go back and remember what we
did in the previous two slides the key
step where we use randomness with the b
sub c's and the hypergraph h
was where we proved the spectral norm of
a power in the matrix a
okay
so the key thing i'll prove to you now
is if there are no cycles of length log
n in the hypergraph
then despite the fact
that my
matrix a is a fixed deterministic object
it has the same spectral node
as in the case where b sub c's were
random
if this is true then we are clearly done
because you know that's what we plugged
in to get a refutation for random case
we'll plug in the same bound this time
for a fixed matrix a
and get a reputation algorithm but
that's of course absurd
so you know i have a contradiction
does this strategy at least make sense
but at the end of the day your goal is
to get a reputation like you're
super confused that's the propositional
kind of proof
i'm trying to prove that every hyper
graph the n square over l edges actually
only random hyperdrafts has an l log n
lens cycle and later you're going to use
this proposition to get yourself a
reputation algorithm that works in some
parameters
okay
but you will it's just uh it's going
back and forth between algorithms yeah
yeah yeah yeah it is but for the sake of
this result
all the so the algorithm i want you to
remember is only the thing i explained
to you on the previous two slides namely
build the kikuchi matrix compute the
spectral norm
okay
now i'm going to prove to you
that that same strategy would actually
go through
for arbitrary b sub c's if
hypothetically speaking there were no
even covers of length and log n in the
hypergraph
and that would be a contradiction
because we know it can't quite go
through
okay
yes
uh you
you have a signing for which you know a
lower value of the
yeah i mean i know a lower bound on the
true value of the instance let me simply
set all these subseas to be one then all
one's assignment satisfies every
constraint so i can't possibly succeed
in
reputation good
all right so let's look at the proof of
this key step okay and i think i can do
it in full
hey
that runs fast okay good you have you
have 10 more minutes including questions
good i still can do it info
all right so
so you know long time ago
my mom told me never to do trace moment
method based proof in a talk
actually she loves this method so this
i'm lying
i'm doing i'm going to do it anyway okay
and you'll see it's very very simple
here's what trace method is if you've
never seen it before
trace method connects the spectral norm
of a matrix to a trace of its high power
okay
precisely speaking
for this matrix a that we saw before
it's true and the upper bound is easy
but in fact this is a reservation that
if i take r to be about log of n choose
l n two z by the way is the number of
rows of the matrix so this is simply log
of the size of the matrix
if i take r to be log n choose l which
is about log n then trace of a to the
two r to the one over two r is in fact a
reasonable estimate for the spectral
node
okay
so to analyze the spectral of this
matrix a that i'm interested in now
i'm going to compute trace of a to the
2r to the 1 over 2 r okay
good
if you've ever seen this you've seen
this such expressions they look like
monstrosities but you know they're
actually pretty tame okay
if i just expand trace of a to the two r
you get a sum
over
you know choices of two are different
row and column indices which i'm going
to call s1 s2 s sub 2 r
and then you know the product of entries
of a
along the path defined by this s1
through s22r in fact the walk defined by
them
okay
so in particular
this choice of s1 through s2r and the
corresponding turn is often called a 2r
length walk
on the entries of this matrix or you
know in the corresponding graph defined
by that
okay
good
so that's what we want to analyze
now some preliminary observations
remember how we defined the matrix a
well there was an entry in the matrix
only if the symmetric difference of the
row and column indices happen to be
equal to a constraint
right
so the only way this term can actually
contribute a non-zero value
is
if for every s i and si plus 1 a s i sub
s i plus 1 equals sorry s i symmetric
difference s i plus 1 equals some c in
the hypergraph h
sensible okay
now here is one little trick i'm going
to do on you i'm going to think of s1
and s2
as their 0 1 indicator vectors
in you know 0 1 to the n
and then you know the fact that their
symmetric difference equals c is same as
saying that if i take the xor the
bitwise xor
of the indicator vectors for s1 and s2
then i get the indicator vector for the
set c
still sensible
okay perfect so
each term because my entries are like
you know between plus and minus one each
term can contribute at most plus one
okay
in fact
if b sub c's are all one
then each term contributes either a plus
one or a zero
which means that the trace is simply
the number of contributing works meaning
the number of blocks for which the term
is non-zero okay
now if
the matrix a were random
and i were to compute the expected trace
of the high power
which you know some of you might have
done in your life
then you know because b sub c's are
random and independent the only way
a term can contribute
is if the walk is returning
in the sense that
every edge every entry of the matrix is
repeated an even number of times
because if not then you know you're
going to have a 0 because expectation of
b sub c to any odd power is going to be
zero
still sensible
which means that this trace of a to the
2 r over there the expectation of it in
the random case
would have been simply the sum of all
walks that are even returning meaning
use each entry of the matrix an even
number of times
okay
what i'm going to prove to you is that
if h has no hyper graph cycle of length
l log n
in fact 2r
in this calculation
then
the exact same set of works contribute
to the spectral norm even if a was fixed
and deterministic
okay
this is it like this is the heart of the
proof so i'm going to pause for like 30
seconds
i'm going to prove to you that even
though a is not random
is a fixed matrix
despite that i'm going to prove that if
you assume that there is no l log and
length cycle in the hyper graph
then exact same even returning box will
be the contributing set
which means i must come up with the same
boundaries vector norm
which means that my refutation algorithm
from you know two slides ago should
succeed which means i should have a
contradiction
stay good
okay so let's see the proof of this
observation
when you expand this expression if there
were no cycles that somehow
the only non-zero terms are the even for
the like the ones that cover
edges
absolutely
that is that is the thing
okay
all right because i prove to you in a
slide
here's the proof
okay sam yeah all right let's do this
observation let's look at a contributing
term s1 s2 up to s up to r
okay
let's recall when does a term contribute
oh i should say this so you know
a term s1 through s2r is completely
described if i tell you the first set s1
and then i tell you c1 to c2r because
you know i know that s1 xor s2 is c1 so
if i give you c1 you can construct s2 if
i give you c2 you can construct s3 and
so on
so i can write down these equations
okay so far so good
now if i add both sides modulo 2
where i'm thinking of these all these
sets as actually the indicator vectors
if you will then i must have so notice
that you know each set occurs in two
equations here
so the left hand side actually cancels
out
if you add modulo 2
which means that so must the right hand
side
which must mean that the sum of ci's
modulo 2 must be zero
any issues very simple
okay
good
so that's what we have that's what we've
concluded
and now it's like a one-line argument
suppose ci's are all distinct
suppose ci's happen to be all distinct
and you knew that some of the ci's
modulo 2 is 0. what does that mean
i claim that it must mean that
you know the set of ci's
covers every vertex and even number of
times that's the only way this can
happen
but there is no two-hour length even
cover we were promised
which must mean that there is no way the
ci's i choose
can cancel out or add to zero
if they were all distinct in fact you
can prove that if you like take any set
like this and peel off all pairs which
are repeated and end up with a set which
has like distinct elements then you know
that would also have to satisfy this
this equality and such that does not
exist
which means that the only way you can
have ci's like this
is if each ci occurs and even number of
times itself that's the only kind of
cancellation we are allowed now
but those
define describe even returning box as we
wanted
that's it
perfect good
so okay you asked about the sam and
that's the last thing i'll tell you
which is um
you know if you want to do this for
um semi-random instances so arbitrary
class structures
well spectral norm doesn't work in fact
it cannot micronorm is actually provably
too large
but you observe that the offending
quadratic forms the ones that are too
large happen to be sparse vectors
and you can actually use this in the
proof using this robot cutting idea that
we had in the previous paper so it works
out
for the odd case you'd work a bit harder
you define the right kikuchi matrix and
it turns out that unlike in the even
case
the spectral norm of the kikuchi
matrices
is large even for the case of random
three xor okay and that's maybe like
that's my guess for why like the vam
approach you know kinda got stuck
when trying to do this for odd
but we show that in this case you can
somehow prune away some rows
and pruning is fine because intuitively
you are again trying to bounce flat
quadratic forms and not you know
arbitrary ones
again won't tell you much about it
but this pruning succeeds as long as a
certain regularity property holds for
the hypergraph
and you know we ensure that property by
giving the new regularity number for
hypergraph won't tell you about it
either but that's it that's the main
message which is that if you randomly
point out the literals in any instance
of case act then it becomes as easy as
random for both algorithms and
certificates
the main takeaway is the kikuchi images
are great
want to prove anything about you know
csps hyper graphs tensors got to use
them
erin should you swap
while that happens any further questions
for quebec
yeah ryan
it's also thought that like um
non-backtracking matrices can solve all
your life's problems so
you make like a non-backtracking version
of this argument where just like all
these even covers like just don't even
exist and so it's perfect it's a great
question and yeah i can talk more
offline but basically this is the
approach i think that might succeed in
removing all the polynomial factors we
have
so i think you know uh the use of
non-black tracking matrix might actually
help us you know tighten up this
argument on the other hand it will also
be nastier as usually this analysis is
good
so yeah together the non-drive tracking
block matrix and the keyboard matrix
solve
yeah
so um i'm trying to
think what happens with matrix churning
up in the
semi-random case if i understand some
random case so an adversary chooses the
clause structure but the b sub c's are
still random perfect it's still a sum of
independent major values
what happens there okay so so yeah chris
is like anticipating the argument for
let's say even idea it's all the kind of
stuff we were doing earlier and he's
absolutely right
the cloth structure is safe which means
that the support structure of a sub c's
is fixed but still they are independent
random you know because the b sub c's
are random
the issue of course is that the
spectronomics just truly do not
because you know you can imagine class
structure that can make some rows very
heavy if some rows are very heavy you're
going to be in trouble
but you know as you might imagine this
leads to only sparse vectors getting
large quadratic forms
so you can imagine that some argument
would allow you to bound the flat
quadratic form still
does that make sense i mean
one could also focus on a regular case
where the row or columns then you are
done
absolutely that's the yeah so in some
sense one message of the whole thing is
that if you are in the even iot case
then the only property of the random
hypergraph we happen to be using in all
these you know fancy groups is that you
know
no set intersects with no set s of size
l intersects with like clauses in you
know too many times like you know about
as
everything is like about equally spread
out in some sense
make sense okay i think i think we
better um
move on to eric aaron thanks for being
here uh i think he already has you can
just leave it there i think